welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber another week week is in
the books in Broward County Florida for
rapper ynw melly's murder trial but not
before a witness stirs some controversy
not for the attorneys but in the jury
box Jamel demons known by his rap name
Mellie is accused of killing two of his
best friends inside of an SUV in the
Miami area in 2018. he's now on trial in
South Florida for murder and he could
face the death penalty if he's convicted
week two of trial has been seeing
multiple expert Witnesses including an
undercover officer who didn't want to
show his face in court as he testified
about local gangs but an important face
that we did get to see in court was the
defendants long crime correspondent
Terry Austin is on the ground in Fort
Lauderdale and has details in the y w
melly's interactions from the courthouse
ynw Melly is paying very close attention
to what is going on in that courtroom
he's being very serious he's actually
looking at the Monitor and he's looking
at the witness he's looking at the
prosecution asking questions I have not
seen him looking at the jury but I
definitely think he is focused on this
trial it seems as though he understands
the seriousness of the case and he's
very very focused continue watching us
on lawn crime we are covering this gavel
to gavel okay now let's Circle back to
the undercover officer from earlier
today because his appearance sparked a
conversation between the judge and a
juror the officer wanted to wear a mask
in order to protect his identity as he
addressed local street gangs but it
reportedly caused a juror a full-on
panic
two messages
that I don't feel comfortable why does
he get to see us but we can't see him
that's your message to me and the second
part was I need a moment I can't listen
properly when I was a child I've seen
someone get robbed and I'm having an
anxiety attack
and I guess my concern is
are you able to
sit as a juror you think it's too much
for you I'm trying to trying to figure
out and that's what we took out of like
a little extended lunch break
figure out whether you're you feel
comfortable and you're up to
yes I feel comfortable but I just don't
think it was appropriating for someone
to be messed up with her I'm impressive
you don't know what people have been
through so it's just like it's shocked
so um
foreign
I think you'd be able to follow those
instructions and you pay attention to
the Evans where you think that you're
concerned about the
the masking that is going to affect your
ability to follow the instructions and
follow the evidence if I can listen upon
the evidence
the anxiety issue we're past that you're
okay
I'm joined right now by my co-host and
defense attorney Brian buckmeyer and
also special guest you see them there
Florida State Attorney Dave aaronberg
Dave I'm going to start with you your
special guest today to mask or not to
mask that was the question for one
witness during the trial how would you
balance the safety of that witness with
this clear anxiety by the juror
Good To Be With You Jesse and Brian
there's a better solution here in our
office when we have someone like this a
gang investigator who doesn't want his
identity to be seen we put on a disguise
but don't use a ski mask that is anxiety
generating when you put a ski mask on
someone look it could hurt the
defendant's right to a fair trial
because it looks like the defendant is
more dangerous to the jury also it could
hurt the prosecution because a key
witness for the prosecution could get
discounted because the juror feels
anxiety over the witness so instead you
put a disguise on like a beard or
something that doesn't intimidate the
the uh the jury or at the very least
warn the jury in advance what's going to
happen and why they're wearing a mask so
you don't shock someone like this okay
so the rubber nose the glasses the
mustache got it I thought it I thought
the same thing uh so Brian you know the
prosecution they continued to try to get
ynw Melly social media and messages
before the jury I think that was an
important point did the judge make the
right ruling with respect to that I I
think the Judge is continuing to make
the right ruling in terms of separating
the relevant information from the social
media we understand that the judge sorry
that the prosecution wants to color this
case in terms of that of his uh his
music his his gang affiliation and
that's an important thing for the
prosecution because that's an
aggravating uh argument to try to get
the death penalty but I think it needs
to be probably connected it needs to
make sure that this is his phone this is
relevant to the information and this is
something that's going to help the jury
get to the ultimate conclusion my
problem with it is they barely even have
a case to put the gun in his hand why
color this case with so much what I
would say prejudicial information prove
that he had the gun then you can bring
in the extra stuff don't put the the
horse before the cart before the horse
so to speak you and I were talking about
how it's really going to be up to these
closing arguments to tie so much of this
together particularly for the
prosecution because it feels a little
disjointed that's something I think
we'll all be looking to but by the way
would have been hilarious if we jump
back to me and I was wearing the
disguise but I didn't know what Dave was
going to say but that you know maybe for
another case well still ahead I'm on
crime daily it is some of the strongest
evidence against the accused killer of
the Idaho form we're learning more about
the match between the suspect and DNA
found at the murder scene
welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody Brian coburger's defense team
is preparing to go to trial he's accused
of stabbing four University of Idaho
students to death in an off-campus home
and this week the prosecution confirmed
that genetic genealogy was used to
identify co-burger as a suspect and they
also say that the DNA in the case is a
statistical match to him long crime
correspondent Anjanette Levy has the
details
Brian coburger faces burglary and first
degree murder charges for the deaths of
Maddie Mogan Kaylee gonsalves Zana
kernodle and Ethan Chapin last November
we've known since coburger was charged
last year that prosecutors claim DNA
found on a knife sheath on Maddie
mogan's bed was 99 likely to have come
from a child of coburger's father but
prosecutors say further DNA testing has
revealed the DNA found on the knife
sheath is a statistical match to DNA
collected from a cheek swab of Brian
coburger basically that's just fancy
terminology for they got a DNA hit and
with DNA it's not just one test boom
they got it there's always a
confirmatory test a second confirmatory
test that gets done it's I think it's
more of a procedural thing James Bogan
is a defense attorney who's followed the
Idaho 4 case the Revelation about the
DNA being a statistical match came in a
prosecution motion asking the court for
a protective order on the investigative
genetic genealogy techniques used by the
FBI in this case the motion is the first
time the prosecution has acknowledged
publicly and on the record that
investigative genetic genealogy was used
to find a suspect using DNA found on the
k-bar knife sheath which prosecutors now
say was found partially underneath the
body of Maddie Mogan and a comforter
James what do you make of the
prosecution seeking a protective order
for this investigative genetic genealogy
material the state says in their opening
paragraph they're seeking to protect the
names and personal information of
they're saying hundreds of innocent
relatives on the family tree
and the names the publicly available
genetic genealogy Services used in
certain
um other information that's described in
the motion it's quite a lengthy motion
now I could see wanting to keep innocent
parties out of uh you know public record
for a criminal case but
obviously you know what you're always
concerned about is a defense attorney is
you want to be able to look at
everything that uh could be relevant to
the evidence in the case
defense is asking for a speedy trial set
for October of this year despite
receiving mountains of evidence from the
state with much more to come following
that request for a speedy trial which is
coburger's right his attorneys now want
to stay or delay the proceedings because
they can't reach an agreement with
prosecutors on what material they will
be given from the grand jury proceedings
grand jury proceedings are secret with
prosecutors presenting evidence to
obtain an indictment against a defendant
prosecutors used a grand jury in
coburger's case it should be noted that
the bar to obtain a grand jury
indictment is very low co-burger will be
back in court next week as his lawyers
argue their motion to have grand jury
materials released to them for Law and
crime I'm Angela Levy all right Brian
according to these court documents
coburger is a statistical match the DNA
is get this
5.37
octillion times more likely to be
co-burger what does that mean all right
so let's break it down it's a
statistical idea there's what 7.8
billion people in the world uh that's
nine zeros octillion as it suggests is
eight rather than billion being two
that's 27 zeros so what it is saying is
there is a 5.3 and then you put 27 zeros
after that that a one in that that it's
is Brian coburger but there's only 7.8
billion people in the world so it is
very very very very very close to saying
that it is basically him because there
are that only so few people in the world
that statistically it's got to be him
now Dave how does the prosecution use
the quantity of DNA and on the sheath
and where it was found to ultimately
secure a conviction
I'm still trying to understand that math
lesson from Professor ruckmeyer but okay
just go with it's a lot a lot right look
this guy is toast okay put another way
prosecutors are gonna make hamburger out
of co-burger because it is a match and
you know science doesn't lie people may
Lie by science doesn't and look they
already have the cell phone records
they've got the white Hyundai they've
got an eyewitness the description that
matches him now they've got his DNA it's
enough DNA that it eliminates his only
possible defense that I brushed up
against that sheath in Walmart and
that's why I'm on it no there's too much
of his DNA on it he's done well those
are defense arguments and they will be
interesting defense arguments if they're
ultimately presented in a court because
this just feels like such a big linchpin
in this case and gonna be very hard for
the defense to argue again